une vidéo c'est bien mais en 3d c'est
mieux comme ça pendant les trois quarts
de l'année je pense qu'à une seule chose
l'été c'est génial avec les vacances le
soleil tout ça mais je mets toujours un
petit détail tous les étés j'ai envie
d'en ménager dans mon frigo tellement
j'ai eu chaud
attention je parle pas de n'importe
quelle chaleur d'ailleurs tu peux
établir différents niveaux de chaleur on
sent que la façon de dormir on m'a
d'abord dame niveau zéro normale ensuite
à le niveau 1 puis le niveau 2 et moi je
te parle du niveau 24
je déteste cette chaleur j'ai juste
envie de demandes mais la peau mais
c'est pas possible alors pour pallier à
ça je fais un truc pas du tout posséder
par les écologistes
je prends des douches tout le temps mais
quand je dis tout le temps ces genres
veut tout le temps quoi était pas
semblant je fais pareil au même problème
dit douch allait d'ailleurs je prends
tellement de douche que je pourrais
prendre une douche en continu en fait
comme moi c'est l'autre
oh non je suis foutu par tout va oui
parce que quand je prends pas de douche
quand j'ai pas la tête dans le congélo
je bois de l'eau ma tante elle a un chat
mon autre tante elle a un perroquet
d'occasions non non non non pardon je
bois de l'eau
ma cousine elle a un vocal avec plein de
poissons asiatiques et sinon genies qu'à
un bonsaï bentalha tout est bon pour
avoir moins chaud à un truc qui
rafraîchit bien c'est de mettre des
idées aux cdec tombé sous les bras je ne
comprends pas le délire de ceux qui font
les pubs pour les déos avec le mec qui
met du déo au ralenti
qui sur terre sans mauvais d'ici pour
pourquoi il se met du déo sur le bill
c'est pas normal et c'est quelqu'un qui
a déjà dit oui ça pue le ventre ici ou
de l'autre c'est toi qu'ils ont du
ventre mais du déo sur le bide
non alors pourquoi
en tout cas avec tous les étés que j'ai
passé à craindre la chaleur j'ai bien
compris un truc
jamais je rentre dans une voiture garée
au soleil et les sièges qui te brûle ya
le volant qui te brûle c'est un calvaire
et tu veux pas faire autrement
on devrait s'en servir comme instrument
de torture voilà pour autre chose en
fait
allez toujours été passionné par tout ce
qui est jeu société jeux de dames on se
ah j'ai une idée combattons la canicule
en partageant ma vidéo sur facebook et
en rejoignant la page je sais même si tu
sens mauvais du ventre et je m'en fous
ah mais non tu allais sur cyprien point
fr pour voir toutes mes autres vidéos un
jour de chaleur
tu parles me de chaleur un jour de ta
chaleur